[Music]
and welcome to the special edition of
Hannity the Russia boomerang in just
moments we have a studio audience full
of experts we're going to break down the
swinging pendulum of Justice now for
two-plus years Democrats the deep state
the media mob all working together
what first to stop one person becoming
president then take down a duly elected
president of the United States with
conspiracy theories and a Russian hoax
tonight the president remains unscathed
and those who abuse their power those
involved in corruption will now be held
accountable now this does include
special counsel Robert Muller we expect
you will appear on Capitol Hill for a
public hearing as the Attorney General
bar has pointed out Democrats they're
hoping to turn this testimony into a
spectacle for Nadler for the Cowardly
shift one more excuse to try and smear
Trump but for Republicans this hearing
is a golden opportunity to ask the
questions that need to be asked to
Robert Muller to hold him accountable we
you we the American people we deserve
answers to all the pressing questions
that our government has totally ignored
and the media mob is ignored Muller must
answer why did he hire a team full of
Democratic donors not one Republican
available why would he ever hire in this
case Hillary Clinton's former attorney
why did he hire this guy Andrew Weissman
guy whose withheld exculpatory evidence
in the past
a Clinton loving partisan hack he was
there the night of Clinton's whoa
victory party that never happened a
record full of prosecutorial misconduct
why did Muller have time to investigate
let's see taxi medallions loan
applications fara violations tax fraud
but he didn't look at the dirty dossier
the lying to a FISA Court the
premeditated fraud committed on a court
to spy in a presidential campaign
why was the probe never into Hillary
Clinton's bought and paid for Russian
lies or what about Christopher steel
with his Russian lies that he put
together what about Glenn Simpson fusion
GPS
what about the Clinton campaigns
coordination with the government of
Ukraine that we have pointed out now
keep in mind people like Michael Cohen
Paul Manafort Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn George papadopolis all charged
with crimes totally unrelated to
collusion or a conspiracy with Russia to
impact the 2016 campaign yet in an
investigation supposedly about collusion
and corruption well no one connected to
Clinton the DNC their phony Russian
sourced op research how did you ignore
all of that mr. Muller
does Robert Muller hate President Trump
did he hire people that hates President
Trump for a reason then candidate Trump
now is this why he pursued an
investigation into obstruction even
after there was no underlying crime of
conspiracy or collusion and why is
Muller given contradictory statements on
the topic of obstruction is he being
pressured by Andrew Weissman did he
forget did you not remember what he said
did he even write that nine and a half
minute rambling press conference you
know at the end of the day is Rob Muller
really proud of his 22 month witch hunt
that really did nothing then give fuel
to what our rampant conspiracy theories
lies propaganda misinformation for
example there's a whole Channel
conspiracy channel M s DNC or fake News
CNN no president in this country should
ever have to face this kind of flawed
partisan phony conspiracy oriented
investigation ever again it shouldn't
happen and thankfully tonight the
boomerang of Justice is in full swing
we have separate investigations into
FISA abuse deep state misconduct
corruption and leaks and the origins of
the Russian probe are all well underway
and according to reports the horowitz
investigation into FISA abuse is nearly
done that was until the 11th hour
Christopher Steele finally agreed to be
interviewed now the former mi6 agent
author of Hillary's dirty dossier was
allegedly grilled for nearly 16 hours
over the course of two days in Great
Britain there's some speculation that
Steele was worried that high-ranking US
officials
we're ready to throw him under the bus
and steal probably wanted to set the
record straight about how his dirty
Russian dossier the Clinton paid for was
created and utilized in the lead-up to
the 2016 presidential election this is
likely very bad news for people names
you know well Jim Comey Andrew McCabe
struck page and Baker and so many others
people that were using Steele's
unverified and frankly unverifiable
Russian garbage
- then spy in an opposition party
candidate Donald Trump his campaign then
it became the Trump transition team and
even the Trump presidency the whole FISA
warrant that was anything but verified
and accurate we now know everybody was
warned they were told ahead of time whoa
Christopher Steele hates Trump Hillary
paid for it and none of its verified but
then they used it in a premeditated way
to commit a massive fraud on a FISA
Court not once but then three subsequent
renewal applications were filed as well
we have big problems in the deep state
but they're now being exposed